alexis poulain bonsoir m merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
il ya bien sûr des enjeux politiques ce
soir mais est ce que c'est la situation
sanitaire qui semble finalement plus
préoccuper les citoyens à ce soir
évidemment je crois que ces municipales
n'intéresse que ceux qui souhaitent et
élus les citoyens qui ont fait leurs
devoirs dont je fais partie se sont
posés la question longtemps faut-il y
aller
elle c'est un devoir d'y aller ou un
devoir de ne pas y aller et si on écoute
certains médecins il ne fallait pas y
aller et je regrette d'y être allé d'une
certaine façon mais comment faire dans
cette conduite dans ces conditions-là
l'incapacité de choix l'inaction de ce
gouvernement pendant des semaines amène
la crise sanitaire on apprend la mort
d'un soignant dans le grand test des
remontées des médecins du front parce
que c'est un front face à ce virus qui
font part de leur inquiétude du fait de
notre système de santé qui serait
incapable de gérer le nombre de malades
qui vont arriver
on attend évidemment les mesures de
confinement qui ne vont pas tarder je
pense cette semaine le discours la prise
de parole du premier ministre hier soir
avant les municipales poser la question
pourquoi avoir maintenu ces municipales
ne fallait-il pas les annuler
aujourd'hui on voit le taux de
participation des gens ont fait ce choix
aussi d'aller voter
mais bon sang pourquoi les nouvelles
d'italie sont très mauvaises également
malgré les mesures de confinement c'est
encore plus de 300 morts aujourd'hui
plus de 3000 cas aujourd'hui l'europe
est maintenant le centre mondial de la
pandémie
on sent bien que les réponses des
différents gouvernements ne sont pas en
ordre de bataille et sont extrêmement
éparses et extrêmement loin derrière la
crise qui nous attend malheureusement je
crois que ces municipales il faut
arrêter d'en parler tout simplement
parce que ce n'est pas ce qui inquiète
ce qui intéresse les françaises qui
veulent savoir c'est est ce que on a les
moyens de sauver des vies est ce qu'on a
des moyens de faire face à l'épidémie
coronavirus et on l'apprend ce soir
alexis poulain le bilan en france est
passé à 120 morts et 5400 car en france
vous disiez on s'achemine peut-être vers
le scénario italien on se demande même
ici pourquoi on va commenter une soirée
électorale qui finalement va peut-être
être annulé un j'imagine que c'est un
casse tête juridique pour pour ceux qui
vont s'en sont chargés si on passe en
confinement il n'y aura pas de deuxième
tour pourquoi donner les résultats dans
ces cas là est ce qu'on ferait pas mieux
de justement de ne pas commenter pour ne
pas donner des éléments pour un pour un
sou vent et aux éventuelles
là j'ai dit ce plan bien sûr toute la
gestion de ce gouvernement est
catastrophique depuis le début de cette
crise que ce soit agnès buzyn qui disait
souris relève que le virus ne viendrait
pas en france qui avait très peu de
chance c'était en janvier sur le fait
qu'ils avaient pas assez de masquer que
finalement les masques ne protégeait pas
c'est pas grave si bête ndiaye et qui
rigolaient sur les plateaux enfin c'est
pas possible
ces incapables même dans le mur est
aujourd'hui avoir maintenu les élections
pour les annuler ce soir mais enfin qui
sont ces gens où est le bien qu'ils
aient des problèmes juridiques il
fallait l'article 16 certainement pas
c'est certainement parce qu'on veut mais
on attend enfin gouverner c'est prévoir
on avait les alertes de nos amis
italiens depuis quinze jours qu'ils ne
fait pas la même erreur que nous
prenaient de la vence
on n'a pas pris d'avancé aujourd'hui on
se retrouve face à un mur avec des
élections c'est ridicule de les voir se
faire filmer en train de voter butin qui
est incapable de mettre du gel sur ses
mains philippe qui touche la machine
enfin c'est c'est scandaleux proprement
scandaleux je n'ai pas de mots ce soir
je suis en colère parce que j'apprends
la mort de soignants dans le grand test
parce que j'apprends le manque encore de
moyens et ce qui risque de venir
aujourd'hui je trouve proprement
scandaleuse premier tour et la façon
dont le gouvernement a géré cette crise
depuis le début et je pense ne pas être
le seul dans ce cas là et être en colère
ce soir marine le pen la présidente du
rassemblement national dénonce un depuis
le début l'amateurisme du gouvernement
on le voit les premières estimations ce
soir pour le rassemblement national sont
plutôt favorables en tout cas à
hénin-beaumont avec steeve briois est ce
que il ya eu un effet finalement
coronavirus vous pensé dans ces
municipales évidemment je pense que les
petits partis et l'intérêt à mobiliser
leurs électeurs en disant petits partis
ce que n'est pas le fn en france mais de
dire c'est l'occasion ou jamais de faire
un score parce que là on peut mobiliser
les troupes et voir la différence
donc forcément c'est ces résultats ne
peuvent pas être pris de pont ce qu'ils
sont c'est à dire que entre ceux qui ont
choisi de ne pas aller voter pour
protéger leur famille ou qui ne pouvait
pas ou qu'ils avaient peur de voter la
façon dont on a présenté ces élections
en disant qu'elles sont sûres mais
on a vu le nombre de bureaux de vote qui
n'ont pas été sécurisé où les consignes
n'ont pas été respectées
je crois que c'est c'est ça ne sert à
rien en fait ce premier tour sachant que
le confinement qui vient s'il vient et
bien annulera defacto le deuxième tour
enfin enfin l'amateurisme flagrant
aujourd'hui ne doit pas faire se réjouir
quelques quelques directeurs
responsables de partis qui ont fait un
score aujourd'hui on a vu donc près d'un
français sur deux qui sont allés voter
on a vu aussi les parcs aujourd'hui
jours de beau temps france rempli de
monde
alexis poulain est ce que c'est pas
aussi un problème de de civisme
d'attitude tout simplement de des
français complètement je critiquais en
première partie
d'abord la façon dont le gouvernement a
communiqué sur cette crise parce que on
a entendu des soi disant spécialistes
dire que ce n'était pas pire qu'une
grippe je pense à des romain goupil ad
michel cymes qui ont rassuré les
populations dont vous inquiétez pas
finalement ça va passer on peut le
prendre est un porteur sain et puis ça
passera toute cette communication du
tout va très bien madame la marquise
elle a fait que les français aujourd'hui
sur les responsables elle a fait
qu'aujourd'hui les français on les a vus
s'agglutiner dans les marchés saluent
tinée dans les parcs faire en sorte de
faire des manifestations sauvages à
bordeaux par exemple
oui hier ne pas respecter la consigne à
minuit et continue de faire la fête
jusqu'à 6h du matin à un moment la
responsabilité elle est collective
il y a bien sûr une responsabilité
légale dans le fait de la gestion de la
crise par les autorités et c'est de là
elle peut être totalement critiquer mais
la gestion responsable des français
aujourd'hui elle est tout autant
critiquable et c'est lamentable de voir
les images aujourd'hui qu'on a vu compte
tenu de l'ampleur de la crise que à
laquelle on a affaire merci beaucoup
alexis poulain d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en direct sur rt france ce
soir
alors avant